he's a pro Football Hall of Famer one of
our favorites from Fox Sports as well
good to see you Hallie long great to see
you what went down in there today Marv I
saw Marshall Faulk and he said that was
one for you that was one for the ages is
what he said yes it's always fascinating
because you've got a room filled with
you know it's a well that people are
drinking out of now and 2019 but the
pillars or the bricks that started the
process or in that room when you've got
people from the age of 94 to the age of
40 you've got a kind of a diverse
thought process in there and and some
people have a more colorful way of
expressing it nothing is safe but who
decides what the topic is like we decide
there is no topic there's no topic it's
I think Willy Lanier is kind of taken
over though he's run the room runs the
room acts as kind of the point guard and
just passes it around and anyone who
wants to talk and you know the obviously
the class from last year who couldn't
speak gets an opportunity to talk and
then people from multiple generations
and and I think that's the important
thing is you know everyone in that room
has a reason to feel good about
themselves sure you know in and every
single person in that room in so many
ways to find their generation at their
position but the big thing that I take
away from it is respect there's respect
in the room and and it's your your team
and as a number of people have mentioned
today you you can't get cut on this team
you can't die on this team you can't be
released you'll always be on this team
so it's a it's a really refreshing
perspective from multiple generations of
the best players
in the history of the game I love it
great I mean just to be in that room oh
just a lot of laughs that's it really
yeah who's the funniest um who's the
funniest hall-of-famer in the
members-only Nitschke luncheon oh god
there's so many funny guys guys that you
wouldn't think would be fun okay so give
me give me good one this is da vac
busting him out
no but you know it's really fascinating
that some of the guys get up I mean you
know I will share with you that it's
Marvel V's 94th yes and tomorrow the
group sang him happy birthday in there
so you know it's a group that views
themselves regardless of where you from
what your ages you know black white it's
it's a family
it truly is it's a team and it's hard to
explain to people outside of the room
but it's it's a pretty remarkable
process and you know deacon and and Ray
Nitschke were we're kind of the the guys
that drove the train on this in the
early years and obviously neither of
those great players and great Hall of
Famers are around anymore and others
have tried to pick up the mantle how we
long here on the Rich Eisen show what do
you think of what's going on with Zeke
and the Cowboys how concerned should
Cowboys fans be of what's going on
between these two who do you pay yeah I
mean if you've got a team I mean you
built your team around triplets right
and you know the quarterbacks gonna have
to get paid and you know you're not
gonna release them you're not gonna just
let go and you're not gonna do the
Washington Redskins Kirk Cousins
franchise tagging plan well depends okay
Bend's on what you want what dude
Dax people walk Zeke I think is is the
you know you can make the case that Zeke
is the guy that kind of drives a train
yeah none of that offensive line when
healthy is as good as there is in
football and you know Amari Cooper is
certainly a guy who wants to get paid
also so just
dealing with the quarterbacks in and of
itself when you're talking about
quarterbacks potentially getting paid
what dictates the salary at the
quarterback position it's it's the
market obviously yes and when you're
talking about dak are you talking about
a top ten quarterback I don't think you
are okay I think that would be the
general consensus I think there's a lot
to like about deck I like Dax
I like Dax make up let's compare golf
and and dak I think Golf is a better
thrower of the football he's a guy that
is a more talented thrower but I like
Dax makeup I like his toughness and you
know playing quarterback the Dallas
Cowboys is no easy time and I think he's
done a really really good job of it and
they've been proving their they improved
last year he feels have been improving
it and let me just qualify what I just
said you asked a very direct question I
gave you my direct answer yeah I think
dak is not top ten now but when the long
and the tooth guys like Brady and Brees
and rivers and Big Ben depart the scene
at some point during Dax career he will
be who has a who has a bigger who has a
bigger upside physically is it golf or
is it back um I might go dak what do you
think you get the other way well I I
tend to lean the other way but my
thought process is the more people you
surround DAC with to go along with the
toughness the leadership the makeup that
he has I like his makeup better than I
like golf's makeup
although Golf is an extraordinarily
talented quarterback I think when the
run game falters for both players they
struggle now who will come through the
smoke and turn three and you know become
that guy I think the more people you
surround dak with and Amari Cooper
certainly had an immediate impact on
question on the offense and DACs
performance well when you send when you
say but the question becomes is it is it
32 million a year or is it 38 million a
year well it better be 32 million well
I'm you know you're
hearing it's it's gonna be north of that
north of 33 ah are you making that face
of like in no way no wrong no I know I
know but when you traded one for Amari
Cooper and everybody thought that Jerry
Jones and Stephen Jones were nuts for
doing that and then the what joke was on
us okay how Cooper looked and how
terrific he was and what he did to open
up this offense that you you know you're
gonna have to pay him I mean you know
you're gonna get some contractual
control but I'm gonna have to pay know
what really opens up the offense is the
running back and that's but and and
they've set it all up so you know you're
gonna have to pay him unless you think
it's off the field yeah I mean but
you're gonna sort of girlie
I mean sudden Wentz I mean like you know
what I mean like so getting it done
early rather than late certainly when I
got it going you got it this is the year
I think if the Cowboys could sign back
to the Wen's deal tomorrow they'd sign
that deal I'm thinking the holdup is
that it's probably going to be north of
that how we long here on the Rich Eisen
show the best team in the NFC right now
going into the season you and Fox
conquer bears I told him you're last man
standing play good that's right he's the
last long stand all right in that regard
the Bears are not a bad choice by the
way I mean that's a that's not your the
Rams are loaded you know when you when
you're it's difficult to bounce back
from from something like that
particularly when you have a dynamic
offense and you go and the Patriots how
do they do it I know I was that's
correct we do know we did that game and
I was somewhat involved in the process
of picking where to go sure and it was
Atlanta was Dallas it was Detroit and I
said look just look at the sheer numbers
New England has been division winner how
many times how many times they've gone
to the AFC Championship game how many
times they go on the Superbowl that's
the place you know bill Bella
Chucky's he's he is the Lombardi of our
generation
fast forward to half time yes 28 to 3 I
think it was 28 to 3 yes 28 to 3 when he
was 21 to 3 Brady threw a pick 6 to
start the third quarter okay so it's 28
to 3 at some point I'm the worst father
in the world
in the world so you know it's uh yeah
but but who by the way made one of the
biggest plays of the game later on in
the fourth quarter Chris that's correct
yeah no I the way in whom it who made
the big play for the Philadelphia Eagles
when they were down 7 nothing to the
Minnesota Vikings in that playoff game
who is the one who made the the pass
broken out loud because on to force the
interception turn into a touchdown and
then the hole and then the roof fell in
yes Vikings and and that being said you
go back to the Rams and you've got this
dynamic offense that's just rolling over
people right and when you look at New
England on tape and you say okay who do
they have and that's why we're talking
about how Ty law here is the first time
he's the first Brady Belichick craft
ourselves era the whole dynamic that I
think you know Willie McGinest I think
guys like that should get in yeah in my
opinion I you know the funny thing is
about doing it particularly if you're
playing on defense it's not about you
it's not what suits you best it's what
suits us best in a particular week I can
be you you could be me we're all
interchangeable therefore we're all
replaceable
that's the Patriots the right guard can
be the left guard the left guard can be
the left tackle the defensive end can be
the outside linebacker he can also be a
defense attack Boyd Brown the wide
receiver was a defensive nono in really
day so my point is for like a guy like
Richard Seymour having played in a
scheme someone like that sure I played
in a three-four straight to gap you rush
the quarterback on third down other than
that you were straight to gap Richard
Seymour's numbers if he were playing in
a different defense would be
astronomical I think he's that good of a
player
yeah good to see you Howie good to see
you're gonna appreciate you jumping in
here and love to have you on during the
season I think I've got an uber outs I
didn't even know how to get over what
you're oh I was about to ask you what
your rating is you know you they rate
you the drivers record you have no idea
my wife does that what do you think May
October rating is tape on this guy Ober
he's got that ankle flexion but I think
we can work with he's he's a he's a
defender heavy like it oh man good to
see a how a great family that's how he
long everybody Pro Football Hall of
Famer for more of the Rich Eisen show
tune - audience Channel 239 on DirecTV
for free on BR Live or download the Rich
Eisen show app